quando sono entrata nel piccolo
ambulatorio per donne e bambini
malnutriti
all'ospedale di hodeida in yemen era il
lui era lì
magro magrissimo un legno
immobile il reale in questa sua magrezza
i medici e le infermiere mi avevano
detto che aveva tre anni
ma dimostrava tre mesi e lo tradiva solo
la sua altezza era avvolto in una
coperta di ciniglia una di queste
coperte a fiori giganti che in medio
oriente
tutti utilizzano tutte le famiglie
utilizzano la notte soprattutto
d'inverno perché d'inverno c'è freddo e
d'inverno è bello avere una coperta di
ciniglia che ti avvolge immaginando che
poi prima o poi domani sarà migliore e
forse ci sarà anche primavera
le mosche gli siano già attaccate al
volto e gli occhi liquidi neri profondi
dentro due cavità già chiedevano alla
morte di venire a prenderselo e io credo
che l'avesse veramente ascoltato perché
dopo pochi minuti
il suo cuore ha iniziato non battere più
il medico e l'infermiera si sono
precipitati sul suo corpicino sul suo
piccolo trash hanno fatto di tutto per
recuperarlo per riportarlo alla vita ma
non c'è stato assolutamente niente da
fare
è in quel momento che dalla dal mio
terzo occhio dalla telecamera che avevo
lasciato accese avevo dovuto lasciarla
accesa non per mandare queste immagini
in tv
ma per documentare con queste immagini
che cosa stesse accadendo già nel 2016
nella guerra in yemen e portare
l'evidenza di tutto questo al tavolo
delle nazioni unite cosa che sarebbe
accaduta esattamente alcuni mesi dopo
nella prima del 2017
ecco che con questo mio terzo occhio
ho visto ho visto levy
lei pensavo fosse la madre invece invece
no
questa donna era la nonna del bambino e
lo scoprì quando si svelò e mostrò un
viso da vecchia dall'età indefinibile
sopra cui è passato addosso tanta vita e
tanta morte
lei raccolse le sue povere cose che
aveva sul letto e sul ciglio del letto
dove era seduta e le mise dentro una
borsa una sorta di sport per la spesa è
qualcosa che la povera gente utilizza in
yemen ed ha anche un'idea
di un possibile futuro una borsa per il
detersivo
sopra c'è scritto crystal forse è
un'ipotesi di un mondo diverso magari
più luccicante lei ha messo tutto lì
dentro e poi ha raccolto il bambino
esattamente con la stessa coperta e
ciniglia fiori giganti
ed è andata via mi ha letteralmente
sibilato probabilmente abbastanza
arrabbiato del fatto che avesse violato
la sua privacy avessi violato il momento
più difficile nella vita di un uomo e
più intimo che la morte con questa
invasività e mi ha detto questo il
secondo il secondo dei mini potiche
muore così
io non mi sa dire il sentimento che mi
ha pervaso in quel momento un misto di
rabbia di ingratitudine nei confronti di
me stessa del mestiere che faccio avrei
voluto letteralmente spacca la
telecamera contro quel muro
avrei voluto in quel momento in realtà
sentivo di rinnegare il mio mestiere che
mi costringeva a documentare questo
momento sacro e inviolabile
ma il fine giustifica ma questo mezzo e
credevo immaginavo speravo che fosse
così
in realtà così non è stato perché dopo
alcuni mesi tutto quello che abbiamo
dimostrato non solo in questo ospedale
ma in tutti gli ospedali dello yemen non
è andato a buon fine al tavolo delle
azioni unite questa morte è arrivata non
ha scosso nessuno
e allora che lì mi sono chiesta in fondo
che senso avesse tutto questo tenuto
conto che in tutti questi anni di lavoro
in questi paesi in questo paese in
particolare ho avuto modo di mettere
insieme una serie di di pezzi di un
mosaico
ho avuto modo di capire l'importanza
l'influenza dei paesi del golfo su
questo paese sulla gente di questo paese
che estremamente semplice ospitale naif
paesi che utilizzano il grimaldello
della religione
e anche delle differenze settarie che
sono state alimentate da governi
dittatoriali
le utilizza per conquistati le ho visto
anche gli effetti del cosiddetto counter
terrorism degli americani quando si va
in cerca dopo aver esportato la
democrazia si va in cerca dei terroristi
e magari ne colpisce uno con un drone ma
quando ne colpisce uno dei file 10 nello
stesso posto ho potuto conoscere una
varia umanità che andava dai locali che
sono quelli che poi noi definiamo anche
giustamente per certi versi i cattivi i
tre visti i miliziani qt anche persone
che lavorano all'interno degli eserciti
che non sono nemmeno dei peccatori di
bambole ma insieme a loro anche alcuni
stranieri che sono quelli che incontrava
il film ho condiviso il tetto con alcuni
navy seals ex navy seals americani che
avevano deciso dopo la guerra in iraq e
di abbandonare tutto e diventare solo
dei contractors perché l'unica cosa che
sapevamo fare era in qualche modo la
guerra alla sicurezza e anche dei
giovani che se o laureati ed importanti
università americane che non dategli
aman perché volevano diventare luogo
della cia quando importante quello che
avrebbe risolto tutto all'interno di
quel paese
ho conosciuto anche situazioni in cui
alcune persone si sono fatte esplodere
nelle piazze e ho visto anche amici
morire e tutto questo in realtà tutto
questo tutti questi pezzi messi insieme
ad un certo punto ho capito che non
erano sufficienti e non era sufficiente
non è sufficiente il valore della
testimonianza per noi giornalisti oggi
perché il mondo è cambiato e noi
cambiamo al di là della crosta in una
strada lastricata da buone intenzioni
che quella di dire voglio dare voce a
chi non ha voce e credetemi dietro
questo c'è anche tanto narcisismo e
molti giornalisti non accetterebbero mai
di dirlo o di dirlo dice a parte questo
c'è un mondo e ci sono dei conflitti che
sono completamente cambiati siamo
lontani anni luce per esempio dai
conflitti che seguiva robert capa con le
sue fotografie dei conflitti che seguiva
kapuscinsky in africa siamo lontani anni
luce da un vietnam dove la testimonianza
dei giornalisti ha potuto risolvere o
quantomeno conclude un conflitto
siamo in realtà ancora anni luce dalla
guerra in prima serata quella che negli
anni 90
invadeva le nostre case mentre
mangiavamo il minestrone la serie
vedevamo i fuochi d'artificio su baghdad
per noi erano fuochi d'artificio per
loro erano morte e distruzione ma siamo
ancora oltre tutto questo perché i
giornalisti come i civili in questi
conflitti che chiamano asimmetrici siamo
diventati dei target degli obiettivi
obiettivi da arrestare
da rapire da torturare e tutto questo
accade nei nostri confronti sia che
agire siano governi giovanile noi
sosteniamo che riteniamo amici e sia
anche coloro che definiamo i cattivi non
a caso quest'anno un premio nobel per la
pace è andato a due giornalisti e allora
in questo quadro il problema che adesso
in questi luoghi non possiamo nemmeno
andare il problema è che in questi
luoghi ormai è difficile avere un visto
visto giornalistico oppure c'è una
pandemia che ci blocca quasi per due
anni
ed ora cosa fare con tutta la buona
volontà troviamo anche dei mezzi
alternativi per poter raccontare i
conflitti ma in questi mezzi alternativi
c'è una trappola spesso ad accompagnarci
dentro i conflitti sono gli stessi
trafficanti che trafficano armi che
trafficano uomini che trafiggono molte
altre cose trafficano anche noi per
entrare nei confini chiedono addirittura
nell'economia di guerra fino a 7mila
dollari a persona
e con questi 7 mila dollari mentre
andiamo a vedere il bambino malnutrito
che cosa succede compleanno armi quindi
diventiamo di fatto parte integrante di
questa guerra diventiamo attivi in
queste guerre e allora considerato tutto
questo mi sono chiesta e adesso vi
chiedo per raccontare confetti a che
cosa vale quello che noi abbiamo visto
esattamente di questi tempi nel novembre
del 2018 questa immagine sulla prima
pagina new york times amal la bambina è
poi morta un mese dopo anche lei di
malnutrizione una bambina che ha
commosso tutti ha commosso tutti
certamente magari in questo modo ci
siamo sgravati da un po di senso di
colpa un racconto che colpisce alla
pancia ma cos'è cambiato in questa
guerra non è cambiato assolutamente
niente nel 2018
avete visto il 2016 oggi nel 2021 e la
stessa cosa se non peggio
dove va a finire dunque il valore della
testimonianza dei giornalisti doveva
finire l'efficacia l'obiettivo forse
l'obiettivo non dovrebbe essere spostava
attenzione l'opinione pubblica cambiare
un pochino il mondo e allora in quel
momento ho deciso basta non serve
assolutamente a niente non serve
assolutamente a niente se questa guerra
continua a essere definite una crisi
umanitaria invece è una crisi politica e
negli ambienti dove bisognerebbe
risolverla non la si vuole risolvere
perché la dimostrazione di quello che
c'è non viene accolta su quei tavoli e
allora mi sono detto ok facciamo una
cosa prima di gettare la spugna magari
proviamo a raccontare la storia di
quelli miniti che resisto ma sono tanti
ci sono ma nessuno racconta la loro
storia è la cosiddetta società civile
che non vede assolutamente nessuno e
allora ho conosciuto ho visto e ho
raccontato lui nel mio documentario lui
si chiama alia della hall su raitre è un
maestro 1 essere più vive nella città di
taiz cosa città lo definiamo la sarajevo
dello yemen perché ha una linea del
fronte e il problema è che bambini e lui
se n'era accorto per andare a scuola
attraversando la linea del fronte con il
rischio di essere colpiti dai cecchini è
in realtà ad un certo punto ha detto no
non è possibile ha trasformato la sua
casa la casa in costruzione della sua
famiglia in una scuola un'idea
abbastanza balzana è andato in giro per
il quartiere dove le famiglie non
mandavano più i bambini a scuola perché
ovviamente è meglio un figlio e
letterato che un figlio morto
c'è una logica in tutto questo e in quel
momento ha detto ai ai genitori dei
bambini guardate non ci sono insegnanti
insegniamo noi a questi bambini e far di
conto lo facciamo nella mia casa alla
trasformiamo in una scuola e poi ha
chiamato anche i ragazzi dell'università
che mandano più all'università quelli
che si doveva laureare e non avevano più
un lavoro ha detto ok
e allora facciamo insieme iniziamo la
scuola ha iniziato con una classe di 20
bambini 20 bambini che poi sono
diventati 30 40 50 60 e poi sono
diventati 200 e poi sono diventati oggi
900 chiede una cifra irrisoria queste
famiglie 20 yemen iria lo più o meno
pari diciamo così a 55 euro per anno e
quindi tanti bambini vanno in questa
scuola insomma la sua storia la storia
di quest'uomo che per me meriterebbe
veramente nobel per la pace ha attratto
l'attenzione di alcuni spettatori di uno
dei broadcaster tedeschi che ha mandato
in onda il documentario e ad un certo
punto una associazione
di donne la città di costanza visto e
documentari ha detto vogliamo aiutare
questo questo maestro hanno chiamato la
produzione hanno chiamato me hanno
chiesto di entrare in contatto con ali
abdallah su rai.tv abbozzato una cosa
abbastanza complicata con tre o quattro
lingue e mezzo alla fine si sono messi
d'accordo e cosa succede succede che lui
riceve ogni mese circa mille euro per
noi non è tanto per lui e tantissima con
queste mille euro ha comprato qualsiasi
cosa ha comprato dai boiler per l'acqua
calda
ai pannelli solari ha comprato i
pavimenti ha comprato gli infissi ha
comprato i banchi ha comprato anche le
mascherine per gli studenti e appagato
anche gli insegnanti e questo continua a
succedere continua a succedere
ogni giorno perché cosa chat e come
potete immaginare piuttosto attiva alla
fine la sua storia quest'uomo e queste
donne tedesche in un mondo in cui quasi
nessuno più si occupa degli altri un
mondo che sembra cinico un mondo che
sembra assolutamente insensibile non
solo al dolore ma anche alle vite degli
altri queste due persone mi hanno
insegnato che si può e si deve buttare
il cuore oltre l'ostacolo che possibile
ancora a battersi per un paese migliore
con grande dignità ed è possibile ancora
aiutare con dignità
chi merita questo aiuto senza fare
alcuna forma di neocolonialismo di
questo genere
insomma alla fine quello che è successo
e che ho capito che è possibile ancora
far battere il cuore se continui ancora
a credere che puoi farlo raccontando una
storia grazie
[Applauso]